[Music]
you probably recognize these ice-cream
pellets as the ice cream of the future
they're dippin dots a summertime steep
but this confectionery treat didn't
start as well ice cream
it started as cow feed dippin dots were
invented in the 80s not by an ice cream
brand but by a microbiologist Curtis
Jones
specialized in cryogenics in 1987 he was
working for a biotech company in
Kentucky trying to figure out how to
make food for farm animals more
efficient his big breakthrough came when
he flash froze cattle feed 350 degrees
below zero which produced small pellets
serendipitously Curtis loved making ice
cream next thing he knew he was using
liquid nitrogen to freeze ice cream at
extremely low temperatures and ended up
with small beads of it when eaten the
natural heat of the mouth melted the
beads and thus dippin dots was born a
year later he formed the company out of
his parents garage in Illinois but there
was a problem Curtis had nowhere to sell
the product dippin dots need to be
stored at such a cold temperature that
it made it impossible for grocery stores
to house the tasty treat so he got
creative and marketed his product to
alternate locations now they're sold at
amusement parks festivals zoos and other
summertime destinations but whether or
not they really are the ice cream of the
future we'll just have to wait and see
[Music]
ketchup so American it's basically the
red in red white and blue right and that
red clearly is from the tomatoes the
ketchup is made from but that wasn't
always the case the first recorded
recipe for ketchup comes from China and
for more than a thousand years
it wasn't even made with tomatoes it was
made with fish guts fish intestines
bladder and stomach all mixed together
with salt then sealed and heated in the
hot Summer Sun for twenty days that was
the original ketchup a fermented fish
paste that dates back to sixth century
China it was popular throughout
Southeast Asia and British and Dutch
settlers who arrived in the 1600s loved
this stuff over time they brought
ketchup home to Europe and added their
own modifications including beer
mushrooms walnuts oysters strawberries
and peaches by the mid 1700s English
ketchup was a mainstay on British dinner
tables and as colonists went west it
soon made its way across the pond
that's where Tomatoes come in they're
native to the Americas and it's rumoured
Europeans once believed they were
poisonous but poisonous they were not in
1812 a Philadelphia horticulturalist and
scientist by the name of James Meese
introduced tomatoes into the mix he
published a tomato ketchup recipe that
was the beginning of a new Crimson era
from there many different iterations
were concocted and by the end of the
18th century the New York Tribune called
tomato ketchup America's a national
condiment that was on every table in the
land which brings us back to this tomato
ketchup is here to stay and I for one
don't miss the fish guts
[Music]
graham crackers often best when paired
with melted marshmallows and chocolate
but it didn't start out as a sugary
snack originally they tasted like
cardboard and they were intended to curb
your sex drive it all started with
Sylvester Graham a 19th century minister
who believed that alcohol meat and fatty
foods led to greed lust and sexual urges
and well that had to be stopped
Graham's cure was simple he preached
that bland foods would curb sexual
appetite and he developed a cracker made
of unbleached flour wheat germ bran and
definitely no sugar
voila the graham cracker was born
[Music]
Graham's theory and his crackers gained
a cult-like following his loyal devotees
called themselves graham i'ts but as
time wore on Graham's theories tipped
the scale of extremism and eventually he
lost his popularity he died in 1851 and
that's when the graham cracker began to
change
over time it went from many
modifications until the National Biscuit
Company now known as Nabisco came around
and successfully sweetened the bland
cracker with some honey and sometimes
cinnamon and chocolate however you
choose to your graham cracker don't
leave out the marshmallow
[Music]
fondue it's this thing we do with cheese
we melt it we dip it we eat it in the
70s it became super popular but that
didn't just happen by chance there was
an ominous force behind it a real-life
cheese cartel
[Music]
a hundred years ago cheese was a hot
commodity in Switzerland it was exported
at high volumes and played a major role
in the Swiss economy but that all
changed after World War one European
countries devastated by the war could no
longer afford to buy expensive imported
cheese which was bad news for
Switzerland so the government stepped in
and they formed the cheese Union
basically it was a cartel and it worked
like this the first thing they did was
force every dairy farmer and cheese
monger to fix the price of cheese
eliminating competition meaning everyone
could stay in the game the cheese cartel
also told them exactly how much cheese
to make and limited the varieties so
instead of making thousands of different
kinds of cheese they only made seven and
it worked
the cartel controlled the cheese supply
for decades by the 70s they got greedy
and wanted to expand their keys racket
globally so they introduced the world to
a dish already popular in the freezing
cold Alps fondue mmm by marketing cheese
for fondue the cartel was able to sell
more I mean think about it
it takes a lot and I mean a lot of
cheese to fill a pot but as with most
cartels things got shady money went
missing people went to jail and by the
1990s the Swiss cheese Union was
dismantled so there you have it the
reason we know and love fondue is
because of a shady government program
that convinced the world to consume
massive amounts of melted cheese
[Music]
you
[Music]
the very thought of Thanksgiving drums
up foods worth salivating over like
stuffing mashed potatoes and of course
the tofurkey but this Thanksgiving
veggie substitute wasn't just whipped up
overnight it actually took years of
trial and error so we called the guy who
invented it I am Seth Tibbett and I am
the inventor of tofurkey
Seth Tibbett was living in Oregon he was
a teacher and a self-professed hippy who
lived somewhere shall we say unusual I
built my own three-story tree house out
of scavenged wood he was also a serious
vegetarian so serious that he started
his very own tempeh making company and I
made soy tempeh 5 grain tempeh and a
sausage tempeh called Temper Oni and I
just made tempeh for the first 15 years
but there was a problem which was
finding something to eat at my own
Thanksgiving you see at the time there
were no main dishes for vegetarians
available so Seth set out to solve the
problem and it wasn't so easy
first he created a stuffed pumpkin the
stuffed pumpkin was the famous one that
we still talk about the whole thing and
the pumpkin was that it collapsed in the
oven and it seemed more like a side dish
than a main dish then there was the
gluten roast which was really an all-day
thing took like eight hours literally it
was just too tough to cut with any kind
of implement that we had other than a
chainsaw which we did not bring to the
table
eventually seth teamed up with his
friend hans he was making these tofu
roasts had a little bit of gravy in
there with them we've had at the
drumettes because we were mimicking the
turkey and marketed it under the name
tofurkey
throughout the years the recipe evolved
we soon realized that this is a vegan
feast and vegan plants don't have legs
so yeah it's been a long journey long
strange tempeh trip as a hippie would
say and now around here we call Turkey a
Tofurky substitute
[Music]